[Applause]
here in this video we shall showcase all
the fights between tyrants and titans
and other large subtitles in the
monsterverse and we shall do the ranking
on our own since all we saw in
godzilla versus gong was a list in the
beginning
that every titan except for kom and
godzilla were listed as defeated
so if you're wondering about which ones
were more powerful than which titans
then watch on since we will show you all
the fights and who are the winners and
the losers of each battle
anyway do hit that subscribe button to
be a part of the mind cue family
and now let's get down with the sickness
muta prime vs dagon chronologically this
is the first battle to be documented and
this was the muta prime versus a member
of godzilla species
called dagon it was supposedly intense
but ended in the muto prime dominating
it
and laying its egg inside the body of
the defeated gojira
godzilla vs shinomura this fight between
these two titans spanned for years
so in 1945 shinomura awakened due to a
hiroshima bombing
and then was quickly engaged by godzilla
but it wasn't till 1954 that godzilla
managed to kill one of the two
shinomura swarms after one was killed by
the hydrogen bombs
they donated in the bikini at all so
godzilla won this one
gong vs the maya squid as we have seen
in calm skull island the maya squid is a
gigantic cephalopod creature of skull
island
and attacked a young adult in kong which
got him by surprise
but was quickly dispatched and became
food for the giant ape
the maesquit is as long as kong was tall
and this was kong's first win
kong vs skull crawlers later in the same
movie
comb came into contact with the other
skull crawlers
but easily beat them without even
breaking a sweat but had a tough time
fighting the big one and was nearly
killed if it wasn't for the help of
humans
but he later ripped the guts out of the
mouth of the skull crawler and secured
the win
the muto male vs godzilla obviously the
fight between the smaller hog muto
and godzilla was gonna come out as a
show win for the g-man but it took quite
a long time for him to kill the flying
titan
the battle went on from the evening till
late night and finally ended when
godzilla slammed the male muto
into a skyscraper with his tail the
muted female versus godzilla
well the female meter was bigger and
more powerful than the male but was not
capable of flying
so the one-on-one fight with godzilla
was easily on the side of the g-man
however godzilla was overwhelmed when
both of them
ganged up on him anyway he did still
manage to kill the female muto in the
end
with a move called the kiss of death
godzilla vs demuto prime in aftershock
godzilla fights the prime and was nearly
overpowered if not for humans
distracting the muted prime
and this allowing godzilla to release a
massive nuclear pulse from his dorsal
blades
sending the prime soaring into the air
and causing his limbs to break off
and then godzilla crushes her head with
a devastating stomp
killing her godzilla versus the mark
jager
regarding this monster battle not much
is known but for the fact that the mark
jagger was killed and it bore
a huge squad wound on its body which was
possibly caused by a powerful atomic
breath
and with her skeleton showing a jagged
rift running from her neck to her
abdomen
so this is another win for godzilla
rodan vs ghidorah
the rodin vs guitar fight was one of the
most
epic duels in the most of us and it had
been dragged on in the hopes of many for
decades
when it happened the smaller road and
did put up quite a fight against monster
zero
but due to its bigger size and the
gravity beams guitar was able to
overpower him after a brief battle
sending rodon down from the skies into
the ocean
godzilla vs ghidorah ghidorah and
godzilla engaged in three
battles over the course of kotm firstly
in antarctica which ended in a stalemate
second was to the advantage of godzilla
off the coast of mexico in the ocean
then lastly in boston way godzilla in
the end transformed into his burning
form
ending monster zero with three nuclear
pulses and also vaporizing his head with
an atomic breath
titanius amhuluk versus behemoth
titanosam hulk is a massive demonic
looking mammalian titan being black in
coloration with ten yellow eyes that
lack pupils
and he kinda looks like a tree he
battles behemoth in an attempt to get
control of the amazon
and manages to overpower behemoth after
a lengthy battle
with both sides getting good shots on
the other
godzilla versus titanos amhuluk in the
battle between behemoth and amhulu
godzilla sees the good that behemoth
could do to the environment
and intervenes in the battle which leads
him to face amhulu
amhulut lunges after godzilla but is
quickly overpowered
and was forced to submit godzilla versus
cilla
in dominion silla is first seen
attacking a ship carrying a nuclear
weapon off the coast of savannah georgia
godzilla then finds her and after a
quick battle he kicks her and forces her
to flee to an island near the tip of
south america
before hibernating in its freezing lake
godzilla versus janitor
janitor greatly resembles a dunkleosteus
its body is blue
and it has red fins with two arms ending
in claws
its massive inner bony plates jut
outwards from its mouth
in dominion godzilla bats a swarm of
these fish creatures and kills the
leader called janitor
by tearing it in half and ripping off
the entire skeleton
godzilla vs tiamat titanostiermat
appears as a rival titan who fights
godzilla shortly after she took over one
of godzilla's old layers in godzilla
dominion after a short yet intense
battle and diamond getting a brief
advantage underwater
godzilla manages to overcome tiamat and
sends her into dormancy along with the
other titans
after sensing vestiges of ghidorah
kong vs camazotz in kingdom kong kamazos
was awakened by humans digging towards
the hollow earth portal and this ended
in him arising and battling kong
getting a prior advantage over the giant
ape until it was distracted by a jet
fighter
which allowed kong to pummel the bat to
near death
and sending it back into the cave with a
punch
kong vs warbats in godzilla vs kong in
the hollow earth sequence kong came into
contact with two snake tyrants called
warbats
and while one was killed instantly the
other robot got to strangle kong like a
python
but was stopped by the heavs allowing
kong
to gain momentum and kill it and then
later eating its brain
mechagodzilla vs the skull crawler well
this battle was quick
the skullcrawler had no chance in hell
the mecca grabbed the skullcrawler's
hands and spread it apart
and then fired its proton screen beam
which burned right through the head and
sliced the titan into two
right through the spine
godzilla vs kong these two tyrants had a
couple of battles and in both of them
godzilla won
fair and square the first was in the
ocean where kong was saved by humans
firing depth charges
and in a hong kong battle the first run
was worn by kong
but in the second round godzilla got the
upper hand and nearly killed the big
eight
godzilla vs mecca godzilla after the
battle with kong an exhausted godzilla
faces mecha godzilla
and was beaten mercilessly by the fully
powered mecca
even during the power beam duel the
proton screen pushed back the atomic
breath
and then the mecha nearly killed
godzilla using the case of death
and the last battle comb and godzilla vs
mecha godzilla
well this is the final battle of the
most verse chronologically and
so far till the next sequel and it
happened right after godzilla was about
to be killed
it was a two-on-one battle godzilla and
gong versus the mecca
although they outnumber him he did still
manage to hold his own
but was later killed and turned shreds
by the combined power of the atomic
breath and a battle axe
and so with that we come to the end of
this list of all the battles and the
monster wars between titans and
other titans and we got to know who won
against whom
and who are the losers anyway do
remember to like for support and click
that subscribe button to be a part of
the mind cue family
and hit that bell button for regular
updates on master videos
right here on minecube take care fam